let's say I have a line let me make it a
straight line as the equation of that
line since it's running in the
horizontal direction it's going to be Y
is equal to some constant so let me
write that so the equation of this line
right here is y is equal to K let's say
I have some other point I'll call that
well I will call that a focus because it
will be a focus let's say that point
let's put it right here is the
coordinate I don't know let's call it a
comma B and let's think about the set of
all points or the locus of all points
that are equidistant to this point right
here and this line and for our just so
you get the terminology we call we'll
call this line a directrix let me write
that down
directrix it's probably a word you've
never heard before directrix and frankly
I've never heard it outside of the
context of of parabolas or conic
sections in general so let's call that a
directrix this is our focus and what we
want to do is we want to find all of the
points in the XY plane that are
equidistant to this focus and this
directrix oh you know there's one point
that just by looking at it we could say
is going to be in our locus so it's
going to be right there because clearly
this point is equidistant it's halfway
between that point and this line now
let's see what other points there
probably be at this point right here
because the distance from there to there
is the same as the distance from if you
just drop us line straight down remember
we want to get the shortest distance
between this point in the line we could
have said something like this distance
but this distance wouldn't be the
shortest distance between this point
this line so you would go straight down
to the line there likewise this point
would be there so that distance is the
same as that distance and you could
already I think
begin to imagine the type of shape this
is and if you look at the title of this
video you can probably guess where this
is going that the shape is going to look
something like the shape is going to
look something like this
or something pretty similar to what we
know as a parabola actually it will be a
parabola there's no no mystery there but
what we're going to do in this video is
actually show you that it's a parabola
show it to you mathematically instead of
this little drawing here where I show
you that now you know it kind of looks
like would be a parabola because this
distance right here looks about the same
as that distance right there you know we
got could keep going up and down the
curve and keep doing that but that
that's not satisfactory let's let's
actually mathematically show that the
locus of all points that are equidistant
to this point and this line this focus
and this directrix is in fact a parabola
so let's say I have some point that's in
this locus and let me call it let me
call the point here let me do it a
different color because it's the same
color as my directrix X Y so I want to
find all of the XY z-- all of the points
that satisfy an equation where their
distance to the focus is equal to their
distance to the directrix so what's the
distance between X Y and the focus
what's this distance right here d1 well
we just used the distance formula it's X
minus the x coordinate of the focus so
it's X minus a squared so the difference
in the X is squared plus the difference
in the Y squared Y minus B squared the
square root of that so this is the
distance to the focus so that I'll call
that d1 that's this distance right there
and we want to find all of the x and y's
where the distance to the focus is equal
to the distance to this line right there
so if we call this distance let me let's
call this the d2 the distance to the
directrix
so the distance to the focus is going to
be equal to D 2 and D 2 what's this
going to be equal to well it's just the
a it's just the the difference in Y
right because no matter where we are
we're just going to drop down straight
to the directrix so the difference in Y
I could just say Y minus K that would be
the difference in Y but in this case I
did make it so that this the coordinate
up here is higher than the
hey over here but what if we had a
situation where this point was below
this line I mean there's nothing here
that I've said that we can only deal
with points above this line we haven't
proven that to ourselves yet so to make
sure that this distance is positive we
could take the absolute value or we
could just square it and then take the
square root and then that ensures that
we're not dealing with negative
distances so here we set up the equation
for all of the X and X's and Y's where
the distance to the focus is equal to
the distance to the directrix so let's
see if this actually turns out to be a
parabola so the first thing we can do is
we can square both sides and get rid of
the radicals so we get X minus a squared
radicals aren't good well not I want to
I don't make any social commentary so X
minus a squared plus y minus B squared
is equal to square the other side Y
minus K squared and right now at least
it looks like you know there's going to
be some Y squared terms and we know I
mean there's definitely neck's squared
term that doesn't seem like it's a
parabola right now but let's let's keep
keep going forward so let me this is X
minus a squared and then let me square
these they live actually expand these
two binomials so plus y squared minus 2y
B plus B squared is equal to Y squared
minus 2y k plus K squared and what can
we do to simplify this well we have a Y
squared here and we have a Y squared on
the right hand side so we can subtract Y
squared from both sides of the equation
they cancel out and then we got rid of
the Y squared so all of a sudden this is
starting to look a lot more like a
parabola because we have this this is
now an equation that relates Y's to an x
squared so let's clean this up and and
and actually make sure that we can get
it in a form that we normally associate
with a parabola so we now have just
rewrite it X minus a squared minus 2y B
plus B squared
is equal to minus 2y k plus K squared
now what can we do let's take all the
Y's and the constants on one side of the
equation so if we if we move both of
these terms on to the right hand side so
we want to add 2 YB to both sides so we
get X minus a squared is equal to I'm
moving both of these terms to the right
hand side so if we add 2 YB to both
sides then we'll have a positive 2 IB on
the right hand side so 2 YB and then
we'll have that minus 2yk right there
minus 2y k and then we're subtracting B
squared from both sides so it's minus B
squared plus K squared I just
arbitrarily decided to write whatever I
transferred from the left-hand side to
the right-hand side in magenta just so
maybe it makes it a little bit clearer
and let's see if we can simplify this
further and remember and just so you
know what I'm doing this whole time in
the back of my mind I'm trying to get it
into the format that that is very that I
normally associate with a parabola and
I'll do it in the corner here just so
you know where the algebra is going I'm
trying to get into a format X minus a
squared is equal to Y y minus B because
if we have it in this form or actually
ax let me rewrite that because I went
too far to the right a times X - well
actually I already use the a so let me
write X - I don't know I'll make up X -
I'll call that you know I don't know V
squared I'm picking maybe V for x value
of the vertex and I'm making up
variables on the fly a times X minus V
squared is equal to Y minus B and you
know the lacks what letters I choose
don't matter but this is a general form
of a parabola this is where I'm trying
to go if I can get this thing that we're
working on to this form that we know
we're dealing with a parabola and then
we can actually relate what we normally
associate with the parabola to these
terms up here and obviously these are
different letters and these letters and
then we can try to figure out if we have
a parabola how do we figure out its its
focus and its
directrix but anyway that was a bit of
an aside just so you know where we're
going so let's try to simplify this a
little bit more so we get my phone is
ringing
now let me silent it so we get X minus a
squared is equal to let's see if we
factor out a 2 and a Y we get let me
factor out a Y first we get to be minus
2 K times y and then I want to make it
minus some some constant so this is a
constant right here this is one constant
squared plus another constant so I could
make this equal to minus minus let me
think about this this would be minus B
squared minus K squared right if I
expand this minus out you would get
minus B squared plus K squared so these
are the say this is the same thing right
there and let's see can i factor out
yeah I can factor out a 2 so I then I
get the whole thing becomes X minus a
squared is equal to 2 times B minus K
times y minus and now this is the
difference of yeah this is B plus K
times B minus K you you might want to
review the factoring factoring
polynomials or factoring factoring
polynomials if that doesn't look
familiar but this is B plus K times B
minus K and I want to do that because I
saw this B minus K out there so that
looked interesting to get it on both
terms right there let's see if we divide
everything times let's see if we divide
everything let's divide everything by 1
over 2 B minus K because I just want a
why here so I have some coefficient in
front of the Y so let's divide
everything by 1 over 2 B minus K so then
you get 1 let me do it down here so I
have some space 1 over 2 B minus K times
X minus a squared is equal to well I'm
dividing this by 2 B minus K so that
goes away so it's Y minus
so if I divide this by to be minus K the
B minus K is canceled out and I'm just
left with B plus K B plus K over two and
I think I have gotten it in the form
that I wanted right in this case the the
a that I wrote up here is now 1 over 2 B
minus K this V is this a that I did here
the Y is y and then my constant term is
out here
so I have hopefully shown to you that
the locus of all points that are
equidistant to this point which is
really just an arbitrary point I said
it's the point a B and some line is in
fact a parabola and that's one of the
ways that people define a parabola and
we'll actually see soon that when you
actually change this relation in this
case we found that all of the points
that are equidistant to the focus and
the directrix if we change that ratio if
we find all of the points that are half
as far away from the directrix as the
focus we start getting another conic
section if we said twice as far we would
get another conic section so this is a
very interesting way of relating you
know sometimes the conic sections in the
first video I showed how they're all
related to cutting the 3-dimensional
cone but they're also related in this
way and and eventually I want to relate
this to the 3-dimensional cone so you
can see how it all fits together which
is always the fun thing about
mathematics so this so far all we've
shown to you is if if we if we do take
the locus of all points that are
equidistant to a point and a directrix
that it is a parabola now the
interesting thing to do is let's say I
have a parabola let's say I have a
parabola let me give a general form let
me see and I'll try to use different
letters than I used up here so let's say
I have a parabola Y - let's call it y1
right where it's just a particular point
on the parabola Y - y1 or you can call
it some constant is equal to let's cause
you know I want to use a capital A just
because that's that tends to be the when
I use a capital A and just know that
it's different than this lowercase a
some capital a times
X minus x1 squared whenever you see it y
sub 1 or an X sub 1 that means you're
actually dealing with a constant term if
you see just an X or Y that generally
means that you're you dealing with a
variable term so these are constants I
could have put a letters there I could
have put a and B there but then that
would have gotten confused with that but
let's see if we can relate these letters
because this is something that we
normally see and then we want to find
the focus or the directrix of a parabola
like this how can we relate these to
these values right here how does how
does K and a and B relate to these right
there so let's see if we can set that up
so if we just pattern match that is a if
we say X 1 is lowercase a actually
that's a straight up pattern match so we
can already write that on the side X 1
is equal to a so whatever x value have
here this is also the x-value of the
focus point which makes sense because in
this case we already learned this in
previous video but we learned that the
vertex is the vertex of this parabola is
the point x1 comma y1 anyway I don't
want to confuse you actually you know
what I'm going to do I don't want to go
too far off into this topic and I think
this video is already gotten long enough
I will continue this in the next video
see you soon